this is Santa it's a bunch of numbers
that represent how many times a bunch of
different people so these numbers
represent a number twice that a bunch of
different people each one of these
represents a single person how many
times they saw the doctor just have a
look at the numbers would be for a
minute okay
you might notice there are two really
healthy people who are the people the
zeros that you're actually having Benson
dr. goal there's sort of a lot of people
who've lost whatever thought to say it's
a month to see the doctor twice that
seems to have happened quite a lot this
one person who's a lot more sick than
the rest of them is that taking there's
an eight just one of them right there
sort of so you've noticed a few things
in the dark the most important thing I
want you to notice is it's really kind
of a discombobulated mess there's no
order to it whatsoever it's just kind of
matter
maybe it's enough medical enough but
that water is not very useful for me and
tragic understand this situation so the
head of you may want frequency tables
what we're going to do is create a
frequency table out of this which as
you're going to see is a much more
orderly way of doing it so in your
spreadsheet here's what I'd like you to
do at the top we're gonna do a couple of
columns first so the first one is what I
say this dad was about what'd I say the
numbers represented the number of times
people way to the doctor so let's call
these doctor visits okay and for reasons
that will become clear in a second of
them ask you to put on X at the end now
we know after that in your first follow
my second column because this is a
frequency table
my second card is going to be frequency
so this means how many times has that
particular thing how frequently right so
I'm going to say frequency I'm gonna
pull that yeah okay
so don't you visit and free
see I'm gonna have another column in a
second but we'll get to that in a minute
okay
now coming back to this guy here this
random set of dot I didn't just come I
didn't just make this up I actually came
up with it from your textbook vision
where I'd like you to look now if you go
to 75 in your intersection statistical
analysis and many make done this is the
table that you should see in front of
you okay so I'll give you a second to
catch up today I don't know what page of
the PDF it is let's see 29 page 29 of
that particular chapter so I want you to
have a look at this frequency table and
see how it represents that mismatch that
mishmash of different numbers that I had
before okay
who those healthy people again open top
you see is five of them right you see
how very sadly I'm not because dankey
this egg's
question what happened to these roads
why is it like there are one two three
everything's nice and it is nothing in
it what happened it why do you get to
speak up very good yeah so you guys
don't have this in your textbook cause I
have so many normal base of the table
but look there are fives sixes no 7c
following me so far so since I don't
have any of those I don't feel the need
to include them as a row in my table
like so last thing I'll point out is did
you remember how I said wow there's a
lot of twos right and you can see
exactly how many to zero that means that
two is 1x a special name it's called the
SAS mission I suppose save it as that's
where the name is not very helpful
because most of the words are we going
to use today and starving them okay but
that's the motive the most common one
and he said I'd like us to do we worry
about these not busier in your
spreadsheet which looks currently like
this doctor visits and in frequency what
I love is doing is to for now this is
the sort of manual part I'd like us to
take those not as problem the textbook
that's
I'll do it imported them then we can
actually do something so go ahead take
those others and shut them into a
spreadsheet
I'll just take a second okay can you
just give me a quick thumbs up if and
when and I expect there will be
different times for everyone you've got
all of those numbers in there just keep
going until you already I'm just
watching until you give me a thumbs up
yeah thank you
yep okay maybe just a few more excellent
thank you very much okay now what we're
gonna do here is use this frequency
table to work out a few things okay so
the first thing we've already actually
worked out was the mode what was it
again it was two very good so maybe what
we want to do is just um leave a few
rows down underneath your table and I'm
just gonna write mode equals two I'm
doing that just pseudo also you have to
have a book on the table at the same
time eventually we're going to write
this in our books but for now just write
that we've already calculated it the
mode is of course of a strip of theme so
we can just read that off the table okay
and hopefully we all agree the reading
of the frequency table is a lot more
efficient than doing it here hello yeah
okay fantastic
now the next thing I want to do is uh
Marie is just one of the measures of the
sensor photography right we have two
other ways to measure what's sort of the
center of this group what are they they
both also start now we've got the medium
which is
again begin it's the middle school cup
that second
what's the other one besides that it's
the main just another one for test it
okay
now have a look at my daughter here if I
just gave you this we're not giving you
the table right what would you do to
calculate the mean the average of this
what you do I just go plus plus plus
plus plus this would take quite some
time because there's so many value to
your K and then after you've added you
divide by half of any their up however
because we have this in a frequency
table this is tons easier for starters
okay underneath way you've got frequency
what I'd like you to use procedures now
in Excel and any kind of other
spreadsheet software some of you notice
to others you've been targeted for the
equals indicates hand computer I want
you go calculate some stuff right now I
want you solve this expression I'm gonna
give me here's what I'd like you to
write them yes if you try that again if
you've got a pretty normal spreadsheet
me so I can't get your hands bother who
is actually using it so okay who's using
something different from students cheat
sheets anyone else okay it should say
the same thing better right it
recognizes oh you want to do it fee I'm
going to bracket so I've got a young
bracket here equals some and then what
I'm going to do is watch carefully just
watch out on the screen for so you can
see my mouse cursor right what I'm going
to do is I want to add up all of the
people in my group right so I'm gonna
use my mouse watch carefully and I'm
going to highlight all of these guys
okay now all you press anything else
have a look at what it's like okay I
picked all of these guys because if I
had them up there's five people who were
really healthy there's our one who
resents obviously something's going on
is these 14 I'm just hanging up all of
them right well you see down here what
does b2
that's exactly right a keep the
coordinates of where the numbers are
busy :
choose your road and then be seven of
course same column but it's it's lower
down at the seventh row okay because
we've started a bracket when you started
rapid you have to plant your right knee
up close it so let's close that and it's
ready good now if I percent time a few
percent on it should tell me without
having to count regularly because why do
that you get a computer to it it should
tell you exactly how many people there
are very good now cover it up a little
bit I actually don't need that over to
the third column you might have seen
from the tips the third column has a
name it's called what's the name of the
third that's pretty good so you can
write that as the top after now if we
wanted to do the mean right let's just
go back to the dock as a new ship we
have to add all these know that and we
have to divide by how many scores we've
got by the way we now know there are in
a second but before I do that I've got
to work out what all of these are equal
to now we've already agreed it would
take a long time to just go plus plus
plus plus plus plus so instead of doing
that I'll say you know those twos right
how many twos are there yet they're 14
so I just took all the tubes and added
them up that would be equal to 28
humor me where did you get 28 14 times
to 14 months of to write when you come
to your table in other words
pressing equals upside for me next year
14 equals it's that 14 now I'm just
going to click on that 14 and there's no
x button on my keyboard but the
substitute for that is the asterisk so
if you question eight on your keyboard
that'll give me an asterisk
that's ossification it's 14 times to
write this number over here okay how
does that look give me a thumbs up that
looks alright but yours yeah okay thank
you so far it's it's all well not it
gives me the number that you guys
calculated before now watch carefully
for the stepping up eyes up for a second
eyes up
see what I'm putting there that 28 right
if you don't click on your 28 you'll
find it's not really another it's a
formula it's calculating this for you
okay so what I can do is I can take that
formula 28 right there I'm gonna copy it
your mo you copied it something an
answer running around okay and then what
I'm gonna do is I'll do this postures
you can see what I'm doing I've
highlighted this entire third color of
highlight all the cell's there and
instead of like typing in every formula
I'm just gonna paste in one here I've
copied that one formula
press ctrl V to paste and now hopefully
it's temporary
do you have the same company should I do
0 6 28 920 and then 8 left on the wallet
okay so give your like wait what just
happened then I'll just repeat it I took
this one cell this one here we had
written the formula today I copied that
born out and then I pasted it into every
cell how are we doing so far
yep is there any gonna be like up until
he lost yeah okay you can enjoy a little
go about because if your spreadsheets
okay yeah we should be able to make
Davison say as well